YUFEI ZHAO: The goal for
the next few lecturers
is to prove Freiman's theorem,
which we discussed last time.
And so we started with
this tool that we proved
called the Plunnecke-Ruzsa
inequality,
which tells us that if you have
a set A now in an arbitrary
abelian group, and if A
has controlled doubling,
it has bounded
doubling, then all
the further iterated sumsets
have bounded growth, as well.
So this is what we
proved last time.
And so we're going to be using
the Plunnecke-Ruzsa inequality
many times.
But there are some other tools
I need to tell you about.
So the next tool is known
as Ruzsa covering lemma.
All right.
So let me first give
you the statement,
and then I explain
some intuition.
I think the technique is more
important than the statement.
But in any case,
here's what it says.
If you have X and B--
they're subsets of some
arbitrary abelian group--
if you have the inequality that
X plus B is at most K times
the size of B-- so the size
of X plus B is at most K times
the size of B--
then there exists
some subset T of X,
with the size of T
being, at most, K,
such that X is contained
in T plus B minus B. So
that's the statement of
Ruzsa covering lemma.
So let me play to
explain what it is about.
So the idea here is that, if
you're in a situation where
if it looks like--
so you should think
of B as a ball.
So if it looks
like X plus B might
be coverable by K
translates of B--
so here, you're supposed
to think of B like a ball
in the metric space--
then X is actually coverable.
So if it looks like,
meaning just by size
alone, by size info alone--
so just based on the
size, if it looks
like X plus B might be coverable
by K different translates of B,
then actually X is
coverable, but you
have to use slightly larger
balls by K copies of B minus B.
So you should think of B minus
B as slightly larger balls
than B itself.
So if B were an actual
ball in Euclidean space,
then B minus B is the same
ball with twice the radius.
And so Ruzsa covering lemma
is a really important tool.
The proof is not very long.
And it's important to understand
the idea of this proof.
So this is a proof not just
in additive combinatorics
but something that happens--
it's a standard
idea in analysis.
So it's very important
to understand this idea.
And the key idea--
here, I think the proof is more
important than the statement
up there--
the key idea here is that if
you want to produce a covering,
one way to produce a covering
is to take a maximal packing.
A maximal packing
using with balls,
for instance, implies a covering
with balls twice as large.
So let me illustrate
that with a picture.
Suppose you have some
space that I want to cover.
But you get to use,
let's say, unit balls.
So how can I make
sure I can cover
the space using unit balls?
And I don't want to use
too many unit balls.
So what you can do is, let me
start by a maximal set of unit
balls, so with centers--
so it's now half unit
balls, so the radius is 1/2.
So I put in as many as I can so
that I cannot put in any more.
So that's what maximal means--
"mal" here doesn't mean
the maximum number.
Although, if you put in the
maximum number, that's also OK.
But maximal means that I just
cannot put in any more balls
that are not overlapping.
If I have this
configuration, now what I do
is I double the radii
of all the balls.
So whoever takes today's notes
will have a fun time drawing
this picture.
So this has to be a covering
of the original space.
Because if you had
missed some point,
I could have put a blue ball in.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What if a space
has some narrow portion?
YUFEI ZHAO: Question-- what if
a space has some narrow portion?
It doesn't matter.
If you formulate
this correctly--
if you miss some
point-- so here,
it depends on how you
formulate this covering.
The point is that, if you
take a maximal set of points,
when you expand, you have
to cover the whole space.
Because if you
missed some point--
so imagine if you had--
for example,
suppose you missed--
suppose you had missed
some point over here.
Then I could have
put an extra ball in.
So if you had missed
some point over here,
that means that I should have
been able to put in that ball
there initially.
So this is a very simple idea,
but a very powerful idea.
And it comes up all the time
in analysis and geometry.
And it also comes up here.
So let's do the actual proof.
So let me let T be a subset
of X be a maximal subset of X,
such that the sets
little t plus B are
disjoint for all elements
little t of a set big T.
So it's like this picture.
I pick a subset of X so
that if I center balls
around these t's, then
these translates of B's are
destroyed.
Then you put in a
maximal such set.
So due to the
disjointness, we find
that the product of
the sizes of t and B
equals to the size of the sum,
because there's no overlaps.
But t plus B has size
at most X plus B,
because T is a subset of X.
But also, from the assumption
we knew that X is--
size of x plus B is upper
bounded by the size B times K.
So in particular, we
get that the size of T
is at most K. So in
other words, over here,
the number of blue balls you can
control by simply the volume.
Now, since T is maximal, we
have that for every little x,
there exists some little t
such that the translate of B
given by x intersects one
of my children translates.
Because if this were
not true, then I
could have put in an
extra translate of B.
So in other words, there exist
two elements, b and b prime,
such that t plus b
equals to x plus b prime.
And hence, x lies in little
t plus B minus B, which
implies that the set X lies
in T plus B minus B. OK.
So that's the Ruzsa
covering lemma.
So it's an execution
of this idea
I mentioned earlier that
a maximal packing implies
a good covering.
Any questions?
Right.
So now we have this tool, we
can prove an easier version
of Freiman's theorem where,
instead of working in integers,
we're going to work in
the finite field model.
So usually, it's good to start
with finite field models.
Things are a bit cleaner.
And in this case, it
actually only requires
a subset of the tools that
we need for the full theorem.
So instead of working
in finite field model,
we're going to be working in
something just slightly more
general.
But it's the same proof.
So we're going to be working
in a group of bounded exponent.
Freiman's theorem in
groups of bounded exponent.
And the word "exponent" in group
theory means the following--
so the exponent of
an abelian group
is the smallest positive
integer, if it exists.
So the smallest positive
integer r so that rx
equals to 0 for
all x in the group.
So for example, if you
are working Fp to the n,
then the exponent is p.
So every element has--
if you add to itself r times,
then it vanishes the element.
The word "exponent" comes from--
I mean, you can
define the same thing
for non-abelian
groups, in which case
you should write this
expression using the exponent.
Instead of addition,
you have multiplication.
So that's why it's
called exponent.
So the name is stuck, even
though we're still working
on the additive setting.
We're going to write
this, so the angle
brackets, to mean the
subgroup generated
by the subset A, where A is a
subset of the group elements.
And so the exponent
of a group, then,
is equal to the
maximum number of--
so if you pick a
group element, look
at how many group
elements does it generate.
So it's equal to the max.
All right.
I mean, the example
you can have in mind is
F2 to the n, which
has exponent 2.
So in general, we're
going to be looking
at a special case in a
group with bounded exponent.
And Freiman's
theorem, in this case,
is due to Ruzsa, who
showed that if you
have a finite subset in an
abelian group with exponent r--
so a finite exponent--
if A has doubling
constant at most K, then
what do we want to say?
We want to say, just like
in Freiman's theorem,
that if A has bounded
doubling, then
it is a large portion
of some structured set.
And here "structured
set" means subgroup.
Well, if you're going to be
looking at subgroups that
contain A, you might as well
look at the subgroup generated
by A. So the claim, then, is
that the subgroup generated
by A is only a constant
factor bigger than A itself.
So let me say it again.
If you have a set A in a
group of bounded exponent,
and A has bounded
doubling, then conclusion
is that A is a large
proportion of some subgroup.
Conversely-- we saw last time--
if you take a subgroup, it
has doubling constant 1,
so if you take a positive
proportional constant
proportion of the subgroup,
it also has bounded doubling.
And this statement
is in some sense
the converse of
that observation.
This bound here is not optimal.
I'll make some
comments about what
we know about these bounds.
But for now, just view
this number as a constant.
Any questions about
the statement?
All right.
So let's prove this
Ruzsa's theorem, giving you
Freiman's theorem in groups
with bounded exponent.
So we're going to be applying
the tools we've seen so far,
starting with Plunnecke-Ruzsa.
So by Plunnecke-Ruzsa
inequality, we find that--
so then I'm going to write
down some expression.
You may wonder, why
this expression?
Because we're going to apply
covering lemma in a second.
So this set by Plunnecke-Ruzsa,
its size is bounded,
because the set can also
be written as 3A minus A,
so its size is bounded by K to
the fourth times the size of A.
And so Plunnecke-Ruzsa is
a very nice tool to have.
It basically tells you, if
you have bounded doubling,
then all the other iterated
sums are essentially
controlled in size.
And then we're using that here.
OK.
So now we're in the
setting where we can
apply the Ruzsa covering lemma.
So by covering
lemma, we're going
to apply the covering lemma--
so using the notation earlier--
with X equal to 2A minus A and
B equal to A. By covering lemma,
there exists some T being a
subset of 2A minus A, with T
not too large--
because of our
earlier estimate--
and such that 2A minus A is
contained in T plus A minus A.
So it's easy to get
lost in the details.
But what's happening here
is that I start with A,
and I'm looking at how
big these iterated growing
sumsets can be.
And if I keep on
doing this operation,
like if I just apply
Plunnecke-Ruzsa,
I can't really control
the iterated sums
by an absolute bound.
This bound will keep growing
if I take bigger iterations.
But Ruzsa covering
lemma gives me
another way to control
the bounded iterations.
It says there is
some bounded set
T such that this iterated
sum is nicely controlled.
So let me iterate this
down even further.
We're going to iterate
the containment
by adding A to both sides.
And we obtain that 3A minus
A is contained in T plus 2A
minus A. But now, 2A minus A
was containing T plus A minus A.
So we get 2T plus A minus A.
So now we've gained
quite a bit, because we
can make this iteration
go up, but not
at the cost of iterating A but
at the cost of iterating T.
But T is a bounded size.
T is bounded size, so T
will have very nice control.
We'll be able to very nicely
control the iterations of T.
So if we keep going, we
find that for all integer n,
positive integer n,
n plus 1 A minus A
is contained in nT plus A minus
A. But for every integer n,
the iterated sums
of T are contained
in the subgroup generated by
T. So therefore, if we take n
to be as large as you want,
see that the left-hand side
eventually becomes the
subgroup generated by A,
and the right hand side
does not depend on n.
So you have this
containment over here.
We would like to estimate how
large the subgroup generated
by A is.
So we look at that
formula, and we
see that the size of the
subgroup generated by T--
and here is where
we're going to use
the fact that the assumption
that a group has bounded
exponent.
So think F2 to the
n, if you will.
So in F2 to the n, if
I give you a set T,
what's the subspace
spanned by T?
What's the maximum
possible size?
It's, at most, 2
raised to the number.
So in general, you also
have that the subgroup
generated by T has size at
most r raised to the size of T
in a group of exponent
r, which we can control,
because T has bounded size.
And the second term,
A minus A, so we also
know how to control
that by Plunnecke-Ruzsa.
Therefore, putting
these two together,
we see that the size up
here is at most r to the K
to the 4 times K
squared size of A, which
is the bound that we claimed.
Any questions?
So the trick here is to only
use Plunnecke-Ruzsa somehow
a bounded number of times.
If you use it too many
times, this bound blows up.
But you use it only a
small number of times,
and then you use the
Ruzsa covering lemma
so that you get this bounded
set T that I can iterate.
Let me make some comments
about the bounds that
come out of this proof.
So you get this very clean
bound, following this proof.
But what about examples?
So what kinds of
examples can you
think of where you have a
set of bounded doubling,
but the set generated, the
group generated by that set,
is potentially large?
So even in F2 to the n, so
if A is an independent set--
so a basis or a subset of
a basis, for instance--
then K-- so A is independent
set, so all the pairwise sums
are distinct-- so K is
about the size of A/2.
That's the doubling constant.
Whereas, the group
generated by A
has size 2 to the size of A,
which is around 2 to the 2K
times the size of A. OK.
So you see that you do need
some exponential blow-up from K
to this constant over here.
And turns out, that's
more or less correct.
So the optimal constant
for F2 to the n
is now known very precisely.
And so if you give me a real
value of K, then I can tell you
there are some
recent results that
tells you exactly what is
the optimal constant you
can put in front of
the A. So very precise.
But asymptotically, it looks
like 2 to the 2K divided by.
K So that's what it looks like.
So this example is
basically correct.
For general r, we expect
a similar phenomenon.
So Ruzsa conjectured that--
in the hypothesis
of the theorem,
the constant you
can take is only
exponential in K, the r to
the some constant C times K.
And it has been verified
for some values of r,
but not in general--
for some r, for example primes.
OK.
Any questions?
All right.
So this is a good milestone.
So we've developed
some tools, and we
were able to prove a easier
version of Freiman's theorem
in a group of bounded exponent.
And you can ask
yourself, does this proof
work in the integers?
And well, literally no.
Because if you
look at this proof,
this set here is infinite,
unlike in the finite field
setting.
In the integers, well,
that's not very good.
So the strategy of
Freiman's theorem,
the proof of Freiman's theorem,
is to start with the integers,
and then try to, not
work in the integers,
but try to work in
a smaller group.
Even though you start
in a maybe very spread
out set of integers, I want to
work in a much smaller group
so that I can control
things within that group.
And this is an idea
called modeling.
So I have a big set
and want to model it
by something in a small group.
So we're going to see this idea.
But to understand
what does it mean
to have a good model
for a set in the sense
of additive
combinatorics, I need
to introduce the notion
of Freiman homomorphisms.
So one of the central
philosophies across mathematics
is that if you want
to study objects,
you should try to understand
maps between objects
and understand properties that
are preserved under those maps.
So if you want to
study groups, I
don't really care how you
label your group elements--
by 1, 2, 3, or A,
B, C. What I care
about is the relationships.
And those are the data
that I care about.
And then, of course,
then you have
concepts like group
homomorphisms,
group isomorphisms, that
preserve all the relevant data.
Similarly in any other area--
in geometry you have manifolds.
You understand not specifically
how they embed into space
but what are the
intrinsic properties.
So we would like
to understand what
are the intrinsic properties
of a subset of an abelian group
that we care about
for the purpose
of additive combinatorics,
and specifically
for Friedman's theorem.
And what we care about is what
kinds of additive relationships
are preserved.
And Freiman's homomorphisms
capture that notion.
So roughly speaking,
we would like
to understand maps between sets
in possibly different groups--
in possibly different
abelian groups--
that only partially
preserve additive structure.
So here's a definition.
Suppose we have A
and B, and they're
subsets in possibly
different abelian groups.
Could be the same, but
possibly different.
And everything's written
under addition, as usual.
So we say that a
map phi from A to B
is a Freiman s-homomorphism.
So that's the term--
Freiman s-homomorphism,
sometimes also Freiman
homomorphisms of order s, so
equivalently I can call it
that, as well--
if the following holds.
If we have the equation
phi of A plus dot,
dot, dot plus phi of a sub
s equal to phi of a prime 1
plus dot, dot, dot plus
phi of a prime s, whenever
a through as, a prime
through as prime, so
a1 prime through as prime,
satisfy the equation
a1 plus dot, dot, dot plus as
equal to a1 prime plus dot,
dot, dot plus as prime.
OK.
So that's the definition of
a Freiman s-homomorphism.
It should remind you of
the definition of a group
homomorphism, which completely
preserves additive structure,
let's say, between
abelian groups.
And for Freiman
homomorphisms, I'm
only asking you to partially
preserve additive structure.
So the point here is that
if I only care about,
let's say, pairwise
sums, if that's
the only data I care about,
then Freiman homomorphisms
preserve that data.
To give you some--
OK, so one more thing.
If phi from A to B is,
furthermore, a bijection,
and both phi and phi inverse
are Freiman s-homomorphisms,
then we say that phi is
a Freiman s-isomorphism.
So it's not enough just to be a
bijection, but it's a bijection
and both the forward
and the inverse
maps are Freiman homomorphisms.
So these are the definitions
we're going to use.
Let me give you some examples.
So every group homomorphism
is a Freiman homomorphism
of every order.
So group homomorphisms preserve
all additive structure,
and Freiman homomorphisms
only partially
preserve additive structure.
A composition-- so
if phi 1 and phi 2
are Freiman s-homomorphisms,
then phi 1 composed with phi 2
is a Freiman s-homomorphism.
So compositions
preserve this property.
And likewise, instead
of homomorphisms,
if you have isomorphisms, then
that's also true, as well.
So these are straightforward
things to check.
So a concrete example that shows
you a difference between group
homomorphisms and
Freiman homomorphisms
is, suppose you take
an arbitrary map
phi from a set that has
no additive structure.
So it's a four-element set,
has no additive structure.
And I map it to
the integers, claim
that this is a Freiman
2-homomorphism.
So you can check.
So whenever this is
satisfied, but that's
never non-trivially satisfied.
So an arbitrary map here is
a Freiman 2-homomorphism.
And if furthermore--
so if you have,
let's say, bijection
between two sets,
both having no additive
structure, if it's a bijection,
it's a Freiman isomorphism
of here, order 2.
Let me give you a
few more examples.
When you look at homomorphisms
between finite groups,
so you know that if
you have a homomorphism
and it's also a bijection,
then it's an isomorphism.
But that's not true for this
notion of homomorphisms.
So the natural embedding
that sends the Boolean cube
to the Boolean cube viewed
as Z mod 2 to the n.
So what's happening here?
This is a part of a
group homomorphism.
And so if you look at Z
to the n, and I do mod 2,
and I restrict to
this Boolean cube,
that's the group
homomorphism If I view this
as a subset of a bigger group.
So it is a Freiman
homomorphisms of every order.
And it's bijective.
But it is not a
Freiman 2-isomorphism.
Because you have
additive relations here
that are not present over here.
So if you read the
definition, the inverse map,
there are some
additive relations here
that are not preserved
if you pull back.
Here's another
example that will be
more relevant to our
subsequent discussion.
So the mod N map, which sends Z
to Z mod N, so this is a group
homomorphisms.
So hence, it's a Freiman
homomorphism of every order.
But it's not--
OK, so if you look at this map,
and even if I restrict to here,
so it's not a Freiman
isomorphism just like earlier.
However-- let me
go back to Z. So
if A is a subset of integers
with diameter less than N/s,
then this map mod N maps
A Freiman s-isomorphically
onto its image.
So even though mod N
restricted to 1 through N
is not a Freiman
isomorphism of order 2,
if I restrict to a
subset that's, let's say,
contained in some
small interval,
then all the additive
structures are preserved.
So let me show you why.
So this is not too hard
once you get your head
around the definition.
So indeed, if you have group
elements a1 through as,
a prime 1 through a prime s, and
if they satisfy the equation--
so if they satisfy
this equations,
so we're trying to verify that
it is a Freiman s-isomorphism,
namely the inverse of this map
is a Freiman s-homomorphism,
so if they satisfy
this equation,
so this is satisfying this
additive relation in the image,
in Z mod N, then note
that the left-hand side--
so all of these A's are
contained in a small interval,
because the diameter of
the set is less than N/s.
So if you look at how big a1
minus a1 prime can be it's,
at most-- or, it's
less than N/s in size.
So the left-hand side,
in absolute value,
viewed as an integer--
so the left-hand side is less
than N in absolute value,
since the diameter of
a is less than N/s.
So you have some number here,
which is strictly less than N
in absolute value,
and it's 0 mod N,
so it must be actually equal
to 0 as a number as an integer.
So this verifies that
the additive relations
up to s-wise sums are
preserved under the mod N map,
if you restrict to
a small interval.
Any questions so far?
So in additive
combinatorics, we are
trying to understand properties,
specific additive properties.
And the notion of
Freiman homomorphisms
Freiman isomorphism capture
what specific properties we
need to study and
what are the maps that
preserve those properties.
And the next thing we will do is
to understand this model lemma,
the modeling lemma,
that tells us
that if you start with a set A
with small doubling, initially
A may be very much spread
out in the integers-- it may
have very large elements, very
small elements, very spread
out.
But if A small
doubling properties,
then I can model A inside
a small group, such
that all the
relevant data, namely
relative to these
Freiman homomorphisms,
are preserved under this model.
So let's move on to
the modeling lemma.
The main message of
the modeling lemma
is that if A has small doubling,
then A can be modeled--
and here, that means
being Freiman isomorphic--
to a subset of a small group.
So first as a warm-up, let's
work in the finite field model,
just to see what such
a result looks like.
And it contains
most of the ideas,
but it's much more clean.
It's much cleaner
than in the integers.
So in the finite field model,
specifically F2 to the n,
what do we want to say?
Suppose you have A, a
subset of F2 to the n,
and suppose that m is some
number such that 2 to the m
is at least as large
as sA minus sA.
So remember, from
Plunnecke-Ruzsa,
you know that if
A plus A is small,
then this iterated sum is small.
So suppose we have these
parameters and sets.
The conclusion is
that A is Freiman
s-isomorphic to some
subset of F2 raised to m.
So initially, A is in a
potentially very large vector
space, or it could be
all over the place.
And what we are
trying to say here
is that if A has small doubling,
then by Plunnecke-Ruzsa, sA
minus sA has size not too much
bigger than A itself-- only
bounded times the
size of A itself.
So I can take an m so that
the size of this group
is only a constant
factor in larger
than the size of A itself.
So we're in a
pretty small group.
So we are able to model A,
even though initially it
sits inside a pretty
large abelian group,
by some subset in a
pretty small group.
So let's see how to prove
this modeling lemma.
So the finite field
setting is much easier to--
it's not too hard to
deal with, because we
can look at linear maps.
So the following are
equivalent for linear maps phi,
so for group homomorphisms.
So phi is a Freiman
s-isomorphism
when restricted
to A. So here, phi
I'm going to let it be a linear
map from F2 to the n to F2
to the m.
The following are equivalent.
So we would like phi to be
a Freiman s-isomorphism when
restricted to A. Because this
means that when I restrict to A
and I restrict to its image,
it Freiman isomorphically maps
onto the image.
So what does that mean?
So phi is already
a homomorphism.
So it's automatically a
Freiman s-homomorphism.
For it to be an
s-isomorphism, it just
means that there are no
additional linear relations
in the image that were not
present earlier, which means
that phi is injective on sA.
So let's just think
about the definition.
And in the definition,
if you know additionally
that phi is a homomorphism,
everything's much cleaner.
It is also equivalent
to that phi
of x is non-zero for
every non-zero element
x of sA minus sA.
So this is a very
clean characterization
of what it means to be
in Freiman s-isomorphism
when you are in an
abelian group and you have
linear maps of homomorphisms.
So if we start by
taking phi to be
a uniformly random linear map--
so for example,
you pick a basis,
and you send each basis element
to a uniformly random element--
then we find that if 2m is at
least A at minus sA, then--
so let me call these
properties 1, 2, 3--
so then the probability that
3 is satisfied is positive.
Because each element
of sA minus sA--
I can also ignore 0-- so each
non-zero element of sA minus sA
violates this property
with probability exactly 2
to the minus m,
everything is uniform.
So if there are
very few elements,
and the space is large
enough, then the third bullet
is satisfied with
positive probability.
So you get Freiman
s-isomorphism.
Any questions?
To get this model, in this case
in the finite field setting,
it's not so hard.
So you kind of
project the whole set,
even though initially it might
have or be very spread out
into a lot of dimensions.
You project it down to a small
dimensional subspace randomly,
and that works.
So then with high
probability, it
preserves all the additive
structures that you want,
provided that you
have small doubling.
Now, let's look at
what happens in Z.
So in Z, things are
a bit more involved.
But the ideas-- actually,
a lot of the ideas--
come from this proof, as well.
So Ruzsa's modeling
lemma tells us
that if you have a
set of integers--
always a finite set--
and integers s and N are such
that N is at least sA minus sA,
then so it turns
out you might not
be able to model
the whole set A.
But it will be good enough for
us to model a large fraction.
So then there exists
an A prime subset of A,
with A prime being at least an
s fraction of the original set.
And A prime is Freiman
s-isomorphic to a subset
of Z mod N.
So same message as before,
with an extra ingredient
that we did not see before.
But the point is
that if you have
a set A with controlled
doubling, then well, now
you can take a large
fraction of A that
is Freiman isomorphism to
a subset of a small group.
This is small,
because we only need
n to exceed sA minus sA, which
are only constant factor more
than the size of A. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is s greater
than 2 comma N?
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry.
S greater than 2 separate
and some integer.
Thank you.
So in our application,
s will be a constant.
s will be 8.
So think of s as some
specific constant.
Any questions?
So let's prove this
modeling lemma.
We want to try to do
some kind of random map.
But it's not clear how to
start doing a random map
if you just start
in the integers.
So what we want to do
is first place ourself
in some group where we can
consider random automorphisms.
So we start by--
perhaps we're very wastefully
choosing a prime q bigger
than the maximum
possible sA minus sA.
And so just choose a
large enough prime.
I don't care how large you pick.
q can be very, very large.
Pick a prime.
And now I work inside Z mod q.
I noticed that if you
make q large enough,
then A sits inside
Z mod q Freiman
isomorphically, or
s-isomorphically.
So just pick q large
enough so that you don't
have to worry about any issues.
So Yeah.
So the mod q map
from A to Z mod q--
so this is Freiman
s-isomorphic--
onto its image.
So let's now consider
a sequence of maps.
And we're going to denote
the sequence like this.
So we start with Z. That's
where A originally sits.
And maps to Z mod q-- so that
was the first map that we saw.
And now we want to do a
random automorphism, kind
of like the random map earlier.
But in Z mod q, there are lots
of nice random automorphisms,
namely multiplication by
some non-zero element.
And finally, we can consider
the representative map,
where every element of
Z mod q, I can associate
to it a positive
integer from 1 to q
which agrees with the Z mod q.
So the final step is not
a group homomorphism.
So we need to be more careful.
So let me denote by
phi this entire map.
So from the beginning to
the end, this composition
I'll denote by phi.
And lambda here is some element
between 1 and q minus 1.
Now, remember what
we said earlier,
that this map, this
final map here,
might not be a Freiman
homomorphism, because there
are some additive relations
here that are not preserved over
here.
But if I restrict myself
to a small interval,
then it is a
Freiman homomorphism
if we restrict to that interval.
If you restrict
yourself to an interval,
you cannot have extra
relations over here,
because they cannot--
the interval is small enough,
you can't wrap around.
So let's consider restrictions
to small intervals.
I start with A over here.
So I want to restrict
myself to some interval
so that I still have lots
of A in that restriction.
And you can do
this by pigeonhole.
So by pigeonhole,
for every lambda
there exists some
interval we'll denote
by I sub lambda inside q.
So the length of this
interval will be at most q/s,
such that if I look at the
restriction of this interval,
I pull it all the way back to
the beginning then I still get
a lot of elements of A.
So A sub lambda, namely
the elements of A whose map
gets sent to this interval,
has at least A/s elements.
So for instance, you can chop
up q into s different intervals.
So one of them will have lots
of elements that came from A.
And this is why in
the end we only get
a large subset of
the A. So we're
going to forget
about everything else
and focus our attention
on the set here.
So thus, by our
earlier discussion
having to do with the final map
being a Freiman s-homomorphism
when you're working
inside a short interval,
we see that phi, if you
restrict to this A sub lambda,
is a Freiman s-homomorphism.
Each step is a
Freiman homomorphism,
because it's a
group homomorphism.
And the final step
in the restriction
is also a Freiman
s-homomorphism,
because what we said about
working inside short intervals.
So this part is very good.
All right.
So now let me consider
one more composition.
So at the end of
the day, we would
like to model this A lambda
inside some small cyclic group.
So far, we don't have
small cyclic groups here.
But I'm going to manufacture
a small cyclic group.
So we're going to consider
the map where, first we
take our phi all the
way until the end,
and now you take mod m map.
So if I don't write anything,
if it goes to Z mod m,
it means the mod m map.
So let me consider psi, which
is the composition of these two
maps.
All right.
So we would like to say that
you can choose this lambda so
that this A sub lambda gets
mapped Freiman s-isomorphically
until to the end.
So far, everything
looks pretty good.
So you have Freiman
s-homomorphism,
and you have a
group homomorphism.
So the whole thing is a
Freiman s-homomorphism.
So psi is restricted
to A sub lambda,
is a Freiman s-homomorphism.
But now the thing that
we really want to check
is if there are some
relationships that
are present at the
end in Z mod m that
were not present earlier.
And so we need to check that--
we claim that if psi
does not map A sub lambda
Freiman isomorphically,
then something
has to have gone wrong.
So if it does not map
A sub lambda Freiman
isomorphically onto
its image, then
what could have gone wrong?
Claim that there
must be some d which
depends on lambda
in sA minus sA,
and d not 0, such that
phi of d is 0 mod m.
So we'll prove this.
But like before, it's
a very similar idea
to what's happening earlier.
The idea is that if you have--
we want to show that there
are no additional additive
relations in the image.
So we would like--
so if it's a
Freiman isomorphism,
then there has to be some
accidental collisions.
And that accidental collision
has to be witnessed by some d.
So this requires some checking.
So suppose-- indeed,
suppose the hypothesis--
suppose that the psi does
not map A sub lambda Freiman
s-isomorphically onto its image.
Then there exists a1 through
as, a1 prime through as prime,
in A lambda such that they do
not have additive relation,
but their images do have
this additive relation.
Their images all the
way until the end
having the additive
relation means
that phi has this
additive relation mod m.
OK.
So how can this be?
Recall that since the image--
so all of these elements-- lie
inside some short interval.
The interval has length
less than 2 minus s.
So we saw this argument, very
similar argument earlier,
before the break.
Because everything lies
in the short interval,
we see that this difference
between the left-
and the right-hand
sides, this difference
is strictly less than q.
Now, by switching the a's
and a primes if necessary,
we may assume that this
difference is non-negative.
Otherwise, it's just
a labeling issue.
Otherwise, I relabel them.
So then this here--
so what's inside
this expression--
we call this expression
inside the absolute value,
we call it star.
So star is some number between
0 and strictly-- so at least 0
and strictly less than q.
Right.
So if we set d to be
this expression, so
the difference between these two
sums, on one hand this d here--
sorry, that's what
I want to say.
Suppose you don't have--
if you are not mapping Freiman
isomorphically onto the image,
then I can exhibit some witness
for that non-isomorphism,
meaning a bunch of
elements that do not
have additive relations
in the domain.
But I do have additive
relation in image.
So if we set this d, then it's
some element of sA minus sA.
And it's non-zero, because
we assume that d is non-zero.
And so then, what can
we say about phi of d?
So phi of d, I claim,
must be this expression
over here, the difference
of the corresponding sums
in the image.
Because the two sides
are congruent mod q--
two sides are congruent mod q.
And furthermore, they are
in the interval from 0
to strictly less than q.
So this is a slightly
subtle argument.
But the idea is all very simple.
Just have to keep track
of the relationships
between what's happening
in the domain, what's
happening in the image.
Somehow, I think
the finite field
case is quite illustrative of--
there, what goes wrong
is similar to what
goes wrong here.
Except here, you have to
keep track a bit more things.
OK.
So consequently,
thus phi of d is
congruent to 0 mod m, which
is what we're looking for.
So that proves the claim.
Any questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So this part?
All right.
So we set d to be
this expression.
I claim this equality.
So why is it true?
First, the left-hand side
and the right-hand side, they
are congruent to
each other mod q.
So why is that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Sorry?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] every
part of phi should preserve--
the first two parts are
group homomorphisms.
And then we just take
[INAUDIBLE] mod q.
YUFEI ZHAO: Exactly.
If you look at phi--
where was it?-- up there, you
see that everything preserves.
Even though the very last step
is not a group homomorphism,
mod q is preserved.
So even though the last step
is not group homomorphism,
it is all mod q.
So if you're looking
at mod q, everything
is group homomorphism.
So here we're good.
Both are in this interval.
The right-hand side
is in the interval
because of our
assumption about short--
everything living
inside a short interval.
And the left-hand
side is by definition.
Because the image of
phi is in that interval,
especially if given that
d is not equal to 0.
Is that OK?
So it's not hard, but
it's a bit confusing.
So think about it.
All right.
So we're almost done.
So we're almost done
proving the Ruzsa modeling
lemma in Z mod m.
So let me finish off the proof.
So for each non-zero d in this
iterated sumset, basically,
we would like to pick a lambda
so that that map up there does
what we want to do.
If it doesn't do
what we want to do,
then it is witnessed
by some d, like this.
Those are the bad lambda.
So if there exists a d,
then this lambda is bad.
So for each d that
potentially witnessed
some bad lambda, the
number of bad lambda, i.e.,
such that phi of d
is congruent to 0 mod
m, so here we're no
longer even thinking
about group
homomorphisms anymore
or the Freiman homomorphisms.
It's just a question of, if I
give you a non-zero integer,
how many lambdas are
there so that phi of d
is divisible by m?
Remember that we picked q large
enough so that, initially, you
are sitting very much inside--
everything's really
between 0 and q.
So this dot lambda up
there lacks uniformity.
So the number of
such bad lambdas
is exactly the number of
elements in this interval that
are divisible by m.
So everything's more
or less a bijection
if you restrict to
the right places.
And the number of such elements
is, at most, q minus 1 over m.
So therefore, the total
number of bad lambdas
is, at most, for
each element d of sA
minus sA, a non-zero element.
We have, at most, q minus
1 over m bad lambdas.
So the total number of bad
lambdas is strictly less than q
minus 1.
So there exists some
lambda such that psi,
when restricted to A sub lambda,
maps Freiman s-isomorphically
onto the image.
Somehow, I think it's really
the same kind of proof
as the one in the
finite field case,
except you have this extra
wrinkle about restricting
too short diameter intervals,
to short intervals.
But the idea is very similar.
OK.
So that's the Freiman model
lemma in the integers.
And let me summarize
what we know so far.
And so that will
give you a sense
of where we're going in the
proof of Freiman's theorem.
So what we know so
far is that if you
have a subset of
integers, a finite subset,
such that A plus A is
size A times K at most,
doubling constant at most K,
then there exists some prime N
at most 2K to the 16th
times the size of A
and some subset
A prime of A such
that A prime is Freiman
8-isomorphic to a subset of Z
mod NZ.
So it follows from two
things we've seen so far.
Because by the Plunnecke-Ruzsa
inequality 8A minus 8A
is, at most, K to
the 16 times A.
And now we can choose
a prime N between K
to the 16 and 2
times K to the 16
and apply the modeling lemma.
So that's where we are at.
So you start with a set of
integers with small doubling.
Then we can conclude that by
keeping a large fraction of A,
keeping--
I forgot to-- so very important.
So there exist some A,
which is a large fraction.
Keeping a large fraction of A,
I can model this large subset
of A by some subset
of a cyclic group,
where the size of
the cyclic group
is only a constant times
more than the size of A.
So now, we are going to
work inside a cyclic group
and working with a set
inside a cyclic group that's
a constant size, a constant
fraction of the cyclic group.
Question is why 8?
So that will come up later.
So basically, you need
to choose some numbers
so that you want to preserve
the structure of GAPs.
So that will come up later.
And now we're inside
a cyclic group.
And you have a constant
fraction of a cyclic group.
Where have we seen this before?
So when we proved Roth's
theorem, that was the setting.
So in cyclic loop, you
have a constant fraction
of cyclic group, and you
can do Fourier analysis.
Initially, you could
not do Fourier analysis
starting with Freiman's
theorem, because the set
may be very, very spread out.
But now, you are a large
fraction of a cyclic group.
So we're going to do
Fourier analysis next time
to show that such a set must
contain lots of structure,
just from the fact
that it is large.
So that will be the next step.
Good.
Happy Thanksgiving.